we're going to talk about today theme of
the day is going to be attacking the
king and executing the winning ideas
made swords you know winning but here so
attacking the king that's a theme for
today class the very first example I
have for you here you're white you down
material you down a piece and it looks
like a trouble but here you have a
beautiful combination that is going to
resolve in to checkmate injury I'm gonna
give you a couple of more minutes T so
here you're trying to find a way to do
the checkmate in three moves white to
play checkmate in three I would like to
see more hands more hands on this one we
are trying to find a way to win in three
moves I see several hands now I want to
give you a chance first checkmate in
three go check so he has to take it he
cannot go anywhere so check now he has
to take it no choice
check now he has to go here and now
Bravo Bravo excellent job okay that's
how you expose the position of the king
okay expose by sacrificing your queen
and then you follow that with a neat
trick mate okay you understand that
attacking the King attacking the king
remember we have ideas like this you
have to think about it who would have
played this in a real tournament game
who do who would have think of this idea
huh very good you see this one checkmate
in three we want to expose the position
of the king let's do this one more time
here this is an excellent idea and this
idea works thanks to the the pawn wedge
here a wedge pawn we have on b6 okay I
remember that thanks to that it works so
go ahead check he has to take and then
check checkmate perfect now the very
next position I have for you in this one
you need to play like Capablanca okay
kappa blanka nobody you never heard of
him who knows who is kappa blanka raise
your hand
our german who is kappa blanka tell them
tell us a little bit about Capablanca
okay world champion number
no number we have several world
champions will champion number number
three first one is Stein its second is
Lasker third one is Capablanca of course
capablanca now okay what are you gonna
do in this position you got some
advantage here but it's not so clear and
he is ready he is ready to he's ready to
push his pawn white to play listen
carefully okay
why to play checkmate in three by
attacking that King okay yes this
actually checkmate in for a little bit
more challenging okay for you it's not
so simple it's not that simple trust me
you must analyze the position first and
the answer is Knight goes back dick run
okay that's the thing I wouldn't be you
this is at once class I'm not gonna give
the checkmate in one positions here guys
don't expect that you know checkmate in
three and four minimum okay three and
four is the minimum for this class yes
well compared to the previous class this
is more advanced okay well but just to
solve this one don't worry just try to
solve this guys yeah this is the
advanced class of what we have today
okay I see couple of hands but not as
many here not as many as I like why to
play checkmate in four four okay come on
think about it yeah but didn't this
problem that's the thing so that's fine
that's why you actually got the first
move now can you follow it up precisely
and do the checkmate in three follow it
up precisely checkmate in three from now
on who sees the checkmate in three raise
your hand who sees it it's a three move
checkmate now
Arjuna Knight h6 check Kong cannot take
it because of the pin he cannot go here
because of the mate okay so he has to
take with the Queen and now what's the
follow-up Wow very strong very strong
that was very good Arjun the whole thing
you got the whole thing yeah let's do
this one more time this is pretty
advanced stuff here okay you are playing
like world champion number three
capablanca in the back go go
go
check my perfect very good excellent
okay that's how you have to do this
ideas okay next one are you ready
you are gonna play this position for
black and I expect a victory from you
it's only four moves it's not a made
this one it's just a crushing victory
okay it's just a fork okay it's just a
fork yes that's a good idea too but
that's I think that Square is designed
for another piece here which piece is
better to go to g4 here yes he's got it
yes Knight is attacking here and
attacking here okay now he has to take
what is the idea we need to attack the
defender here everybody defender need to
be attack yes he's got it correct
attacking the defender defender his gun
checkmate is on the board everybody got
it he will go here now I want a neat
finish from you neat finish somehow it's
King is becoming more overworked you
know more and more overworked that King
no no no you'd have a shot here you have
a tactical shot and you win the game you
have a tactical shot that wins the game
and that shot is yes
bravo Bravo Martin correct yes check and
now you win his queen that's what you
want to do right
tix thank you very much all right
excellent excellent job okay that's how
you gotta do it to win this game any
questions let's do this idea again this
advanced attacking idea so you can
remember it better okay
attacking the King exposing opponent's
king to win go yes
fork see if he moves away you take the
pawn on h2 it's a mate so he has to take
it which he does attack
Bravo very nice night X here and
exposing Bravo excellent very good job
okay now I have one more position for
you here for attacking the king okay
black to move and win your block in this
position okay you're black in this
position and you're gonna win this how
many moves it's couple of moves not very
not too many no it's the whole thing is
like six moves but but you just need to
see the idea you know idea idea so what
to do here
his bishop is very strong and it's not
easy you really need to analyze this
position a little bit okay and see your
threats like for example Knight b6 would
be lovely you know to attack this
because if it moves away we just win
right but the problem is check problem
is he comes in and then you take he goes
checkmate
okay that is the problem okay everybody
that is the problem
so that's why we cannot play the move
Knight b6 in this position think you're
not ready yet you're not ready yet you
need more time guys this is very nice
idea very very nice idea you will win
but you gotta think
now which piece needs to be you saw the
strength of that Bishop you saw how
powerful that Bishop was you know
causing all sorts of problems for us
okay yes
rook takes Bishop correct he is
identifying that by eliminating the
bishop correct Martin now where is the
follow up to I want to see the follow up
excellent now Knight b6 attacking that
Queen Queen cannot go anywhere except b3
correct anywhere else he goes he loses
it now keep working correct
trapping the queen he will sacrifice to
escape from it what do you do and he
takes back in his yeah you can take this
back but you're not really winning this
do you see the winning shot here the
winning idea now I should hear more
hands by now yes
winning idea and a queen bee 5 queen bee
5 will change you betray sacrificing
another pawn I take you check look at
that everybody check checkmate
you see you have to always look at this
ideas to open up the diagonal you know
because that's what it does you threaten
checkmate you threaten checkmate okay
that's what you're trying to do you have
a question
excellent let's do it again from a very
beginning this is a very special
position okay white to play black to
play and win because you do more of this
ideas you're gonna see more in your own
games okay you're going to develop this
idea sergeant first move sacrificing
exchange to eliminate them second move
who wants to give me the second move you
correct third move who who's got the
third move to force it you know correct
for King the rook and Queen and dropping
it so he takes
now the next one who's got the next move
excellent and now the finishing touch
b3 Bravo threating check on he won and
threatening mate on a tooth that's why
he has to take it he cannot do anything
else he has to take it okay
he cannot just do anything so he takes
it or he takes it with something else
and now same thing whatever he does I
want to checkmate from you guys so what
is the checkmate in the back focus focus
don't rush focus you check now he has to
go back here
check out checkmate
got it attacking ideas okay that's what
you have to remember in this how to
attack when you have the advantage okay
when you have the advantage how to
proceed okay so remember that remember
so you can continue doing that okay
because otherwise in this position you
would make another move and then maybe
he would win you know because if let's
say you make a random move no yeah he
takes you
he checks you he takes you and then your
king is gonna get checkmated because
it's very exposed okay so that's why you
have to make sure you don't do that
okay you have to make sure you take the
bishop or g5 how many of you would have
done this in a tournament game would
sacrifice the exchange and calculate the
six move combination to win what do you
think in the tournament game hmm yeah
you more do you do this more you can
find these ideas okay so that's the idea
to remember for you all right and one
more thing I want to review before we
start playing our practice games when we
start the game the very first step we're
gonna do second step we're gonna do
third step we're gonna do fourth step
we're gonna do complete complete
development and a fifth step the final
step we are ready to the attack so now
I'm gonna pair you up with you I know
most of you I'm gonna pair you up with
your strength players and I want you to
follow those five steps okay
you